I think the colors are light, the stage, build the world
within our goals.
MVP, let's go.
Take the future we seek, never stop your dreaming.
I think colors will light the stage, build the world within
our goals.
MVP, let's go.
MVP, take off our hand in hand.
Always painting your lifestyle
Don't you look and spanning each and every world Let's go!
Let's go!
Painting the future we seek Never stop your dreaming I think
colors will light the stage Build the world with miracles
MVP Let's go
MVP Take off our hand in hand Our colors, painting, all our
sky No,
no, no, no, no, no No, no, no, no, no Change everyone Let's
go Let's go Let's change our future We seek, never stop your
dreaming I think colors are light stage, build the world
with miracles MVP, let's go
MVP Take off all the time Oh,
you're the only one So you're the first planning each and
every one Let's go Let's go We're the future We're the one
Painting the future Never stop you dreaming I think colors
will light the stage Build the world with miracles MVP
MVP Eating fruits Oh!
Hello everyone
I didn't hear that, did they?
I'm eating fruit oh scandalous scandalous eating i know my
god what what do you mean eating fruit just a little i know
oh my god crazy that's crazy yo sorry i'm getting sticky
fingers all over your machines oh thank you so much for
coming today guys how is everybody hello i'm so excited I
made sure I made sure I went to the bathroom before this
Because I was getting a little too excited I was like I
can't
So like I guess I have this rep now Because every time we
would have a meeting Over the past several months It would
end with me being like I'm so sorry guys I have to go to the
bathroom right now I gotta go Every time Pretty much yeah
calling me out but thank you for supporting my uh being
hydrated yes you guys all have water right and also chat you
have water too right get your water if you don't have it
already get your water get your water water h2o h2o h2o yes
yes yes drink who can do the best drinking noise Okay, here
we go.
Oh, okay.
Oh.
Whoa.
Whoa, wait.
Who was that Vicky?
Whoa.
Hydration.
You guys have this thing where...
Do people tell you that you're loud drinkers?
Because I've been told I'm a loud drinker.
You know, Phoebe, when I saw you the other day, I thought
that.
I was like, wow, she's drinking.
Wait, really?
It's a real guy.
Okay.
Wait, let me try it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, try it,
try.
Didn't hear anything.
Do it again.
I want to hear again.
Turn off the noise gate.
Turn off the gate.
Oh, my God.
I don't know if I...
Let me see it.
Oh, I heard it.
I heard it both.
Performed and drinking.
I want that as my ringtone.
It'll remind me to drink.
Nom, nom, nom, nom.
Yes.
Good water.
Anyway, guys, thank you so much for coming to the arcade
today for our first group collab.
Oh, my gosh.
So exciting.
Oh, no worries.
No worries.
Thanks for hosting us.
No, no worries.
I mean, everyone doesn't know actually what we're doing yet.
Do you chat?
Any ideas?
Is anyone spilled the beans yet?
No.
I don't think so.
Any guesses?
Yes.
What are we going to do?
Other than playing games?
Because we're definitely going to play games like after the
stream, right?
We're going to play all the cabinets.
Oh yeah, absolutely.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Cabin.
Yeah.
Oh, I was like, we're going to open up and like look for
plates.
You're just going to steal my stuff.
Like, oh, hey, Vicky.
Oh, don't mind us.
We're just going to take some of these snacks.
I'm rummaging through your kitchen.
That's over there.
Excuse me.
Wait, are we allowed?
Yeah, I guess this is a thing now.
You got snacks.
You got Ramune over there.
Literally right behind us.
Yeah, exactly.
To be fair, I have got everything, but that will be 500 yen.
Thank you very much.
500 yen?
Can I put that into love?
Okay, no, that's kind of steve, actually.
In the 80s?
Yeah, I know.
I know.
I'm sorry, guys.
Yeah, no, you're right.
You're right.
10,000 yen for the ramen.
10,000.
Oh.
That's more like, that's those California prices right
there.
10,000 yen for a ramen.
You know, once I stayed at a hotel in California and they
had instant ramen, like the Cup ramen, and it was $7.
What?
Yeah, $7 USD for Cup ramen.
That's crazy.
What?
That's insane!
Yeah.
What?
Did it come with like toppings or anything?
No, it was Maru-chan.
Like it was...
Yeah!
That's so weird.
It was very strange.
I'm scared.
I'm scared of prices in America.
I don't think I'm gonna be able to afford anything.
I think so.
I'm scared of America.
I'll cheat you.
of america thank you oh thanks thanks i'll treat you to
seven dollars maru can you take me to an american diner i
want to go to an american diner yes chilies so exciting
maybe we can take her somewhere a little better than chilies
that is a classic american diner what do you mean is it a
diner is it a diner i don't know that's fabulous Oh, yeah,
it's a bummy-ness.
It's a little bummy-ness.
Okay, that's something that I can understand.
I have been to Waffle House.
I enjoyed it.
It's very tasty.
Victoria Roman has been to a Waffle House, but I've never
been to a Waffle House.
What?
It's so good.
All the maple syrup just drown everything in it.
That sounds yummy.
Yeah.
I'm going to go to Waffle House.
I guess it's all waffles, right?
stories about people fighting at the waffle house there's
burgers the burgers have syrup too oh you could put that on
there yeah probably a syrup burger freedom american freedom
we could all we could fight each other we could be the
entertainment be like what's the room fight then set to dot
exe anime scene fun anime fight scene yes amazing i wanted
to be animated like how you know sometimes like dragon ball
z will just be like five frames per second or something.
Wait, what's your weapon of choice?
Like the diner chairs or like the lamp or the waffle of
the... Does the waffle house have a waffle, a big waffle?
I imagine it.
In my head, I imagine it with a big waffle.
What, you're just gonna whack someone around the head with a
giant waffle?
I would like to whack someone with a giant waffle.
I want to heat up the syrup and pour it on people like lava.
That's 10 Everybody!
And delicious!
Is it?
Actually, so what I heard...
This is so cursed.
What are we gonna say?
I heard that humans taste and smell the most like...
We're most close in composition to pigs, so like we might
taste like bacon.
So technically it's bacon, maple bacon, if you do that.
Maple bacon.
I feel like I zoned out for one second.
How did I... How did we get here again?
How did we get... Oh, it's a cannibalism?
Oh, weapon of choice.
Poor Vicky's trying to fix her chat.
No, you're like...
Oh, what is... What is going on, guys?
Uh, give me one sec.
Let me just see if this fixes it.
I don't know why.
Emote only chat.
It's okay.
Yeah, it's fine.
If it's emote only, then it's...
It's emote only, but...
We can still see you guys, like, in the YouTube.
Yeah, we can see...
indeed oh oh you mean the actual chat yeah oh yeah if you
try refreshing the cache maybe oh yeah
actually that happened to my chat yesterday too i think my
my chat couldn't handle couldn't handle the the the absolute
energy of everybody oh yeah i saw that too i was like oh I
thought it was a choice.
I don't know why I thought that.
It was working before I hit Go Live.
No, it's okay.
Professional streamers, um, guys, we are in these.
We got, uh, we got a raid.
Oh, thank you.
Yeah.
How are you guys doing?
Oh, thank you.
Thank you so much, Callie.
That's very sweet.
That's very sweet indeed.
Thank you.
Sorry, I'm trying to sort out chat right now, but thank you.
Thank you so much.
Welcome in, welcome, welcome.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
How was your stream?
Yeah.
What were you doing?
It was like Uno, right?
Uno?
Uno.
Oh, no.
Is there something else?
Dragon Ball.
Yeah.
Dragon Ball Uno.
Dragon Ball.
Oh, actually, I can imagine that.
Someone animate that.
Dragon Ball Uno.
I would play that.
Is that a thing?
Oh, heck yeah.
Hmm.
Yeah, we're just going to own it.
We're just going to own it.
Own the emoji-only chat.
We're doing it live.
Yeah.
Welcome, everyone.
Welcome, welcome.
We should be tonight.
We should play Uno.
I feel like Uno can make or break a friendship, you know,
guys.
Are we ready for Uno?
I think we've been through a lot.
Didn't we say that about something else?
There was a different game that we played together at one
point.
And we were like, this is going to make or break our friend.
It might have been golf with friends.
And clearly we're still friends.
Maybe more than friends.
What?
Family.
I did see some stuff on X.
It was like welcome to Phoebe's thruffle or something.
Like thruffle.
Wait, I have a thruffle.
I specifically have a thruffle that's crazy.
Yeah, I don't know what the comment was.
I was like, what?
Are we...
Wait, is Vicky and I, are we like combined one person and
then there's a third person?
There's a third?
Oh, who's like...
Yeah!
Wait, we're a combined person, don't you remember?
Wait, let me find it.
Wait, actually.
Yeah.
I made this last night Oh you made it You made it I thought
you like got it You guys need to see this We made it last
night Combine I don't know that you made it That's so funny
I was like Oh wait I could become Vicky Chats the third Well
I guess so then These are all One many-headed being See See
Chats Look at it look at this beauty i'm vicky
well that is some that is some high quality photoshop right
there i mean i love it thank you thank you pretty good it
took me many of two seconds
incredible should i just leave that there the whole stream
where would bb be where would bb be maybe i want to maybe
like in your drill or something and like she can't be in
drill you can put me in your pocket phoebe phoebe could be
my no that's a bad suggestion what oh no now i want to know
now you have to say my my bazoingas oh i can wait i can be
the bazoingas yeah you could you can be my bazoingas no way
my dream came true i am boogees now
I was I was thinking you know boobas for the have you have
you thought of a fan name yet but you still you still
brainstorming yeah we're brainstorming I hope it's not gonna
be not gonna be labubus I don't think so actually at this
point it might be labubus I mean I'm for the mint libubu
collab coming so oh yeah that's what everybody's been
requesting they're all
now guys talking of stream we we have got things to do today
haven't we everyone oh yeah i forgot yeah you guys we have
announcements later too so we do around and everything yeah
if you want it if you want to hear some interesting very
exciting announcements but first I'd like to move over to
the board game table in the arcade should we go have a look
this this amazing board was put together by a Mint Phantom
games uh and and the pieces beautifully ordered uh from
phoebe hive games and the dice uh imported in from a
victoria roman games uh would you like to explain the board
mint oh yes indeed so we have this wonderful board set in
our lovely virtual akihabara wow and so um what did i make
the colors I couldn't remember even.
Wait, we have this.
Did we pin it?
Hold on.
If you land...
Yeah.
If you land on one of our member colors, so blue, mint, or
pink, you pick...
Oh, one of the...
Oh, everybody so graciously sent in questions for the
marshmallow.
Oh, so thank you.
Thank you.
If you did.
If you land on one of those three colors, we will pick a
question from the marshmallow pile.
And then we also came up with our own questions, or we are,
we will come up with them in our brain on the spot.
Oh, whoops.
Hashtag preparation.
Yep.
We might be inspired and change our questions, you know,
whatever.
Yeah.
But if you land on...
Hmm...
Or orange?
If you land on...
Orange, it will be one of our questions.
I think.
I think purple was our question and orange is.
Land on purple.
It will be one of our questions.
Oh, ERB?
Wait!
Leigh!
Hello!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Welcome, welcome!
Welcome, fellow Brits!
Oh my gosh!
Oh yeah, the Brits!
Oh my gosh, they're both British.
Thank you so much, yeah.
Alright, yeah.
So wait, so that was the marshmallow colour and then we got
member, member, member is purple.
Purple, okay.
And then orange is we also got some questions from our
lovely Staffsan.
Thank you, Staffsan!
everybody who helped out and is helping us out so um yeah
we're just we're good to get to know us a little bit more
through all these questions and um whoever finishes first uh
i don't think we came up with something oh chat can you come
up with a reward for whoever finishes first or whoever
finishes first could make like a batu for the other two
people oh no we talked about like yeah oh yeah Batsu Batsu
really Batsu I don't want to leave Batsu up to chat I don't
know what they're gonna say no no no not at the chat up to
up to whoever wins oh thank goodness they're gonna make me
eat a durian or something oh no wow no we won't we won't let
that happen okay so we come up with bad suit for the other
members that sounds like a good plan okay sounds good to me
oh are we ready and then we've got we've got these dice guys
Who wants to go first?
Who wants to roll?
Who should go first?
We could go in order as we're standing.
Okay, I'll go first.
Yeah.
Real quick question.
Oh, yeah.
Can you please screen share?
Oh, yeah!
Show to a minute.
Thank you.
I think my stream's behind.
Me too.
Show, show, oh, matchy, kudosai.
Thank you.
Is that good for you guys?
Yeah, that works.
Perfect.
Thank you.
Excellent.
All right.
I'ma roll, guys.
I'ma roll.
Are you ready?
Haki-daki.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh.
What?
Wait, why are we out of the loading screen?
Rigged.
Oh, are we on the loading screen?
No.
Wait.
Okay, is it sharing with you guys?
Oh, there, there, there, there.
Okay, are we good?
Are we good?
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I got a one.
I got a one, guys, so...
A one!
Cool.
That's great.
That's really great.
One because you're number one in our hearts.
Aw, thanks, guys.
it yeah she's number one vicky schmortenenden she is number
one i am number one yeah boom boom boom
purple what was what was purple again oh that is oh uh uh
question from us yeah question from the members okay Okay.
What's your question, guys?
How about we start typing, me and Mint start typing a
question, whoever finishes typing it first.
Oh, I have mine written down, so I'm gonna copy and paste.
Oh!
Wait, what?
This is a real question!
Okay, okay.
Okay.
What?
Do you?
Okay, I'm gonna, should I read it out loud since it's my
question?
Victoria Roman.
Do you remove your socks with your toes or with your hands?
Who removes it with the toes?
Is this a thing?
Wait, huh?
Wait, you don't remove it with your toes?
No?
You could...
Okay, that's why I thought it was the real time to remove it
with my toes.
Wait.
I remove...
You know, like a monkey, you just kind of stick your...
big toe in there and
I like I step on the other sock and then I pull my foot out.
Oh yeah that would do that.
Yeah yeah yeah yeah.
That's another reason too.
But you can do it monkey style if you want monkey style.
Okay.
I will admit I think one time where I for some reason I was
like I don't know I was like type and something.
I think I did remove one with my mouth once.
One time.
judging for toes and you remote it with your mouth?
It was one time!
But I remember.
What could you have been doing?
That was so...
Why?
Probably typing an essay about Shadow the Hedgehog.
I was just too invested.
What?
You couldn't stop for a second just to take it off normal?
Again.
I shouldn't have judged you guys for using your toes.
I understand now.
I'm sorry.
Narrow net?
Okay.
Well, there you go, chat.
Fun fact for you.
Who's next?
Who expected that?
Minto, minto.
It's me!
Three!
Three, three, three, three.
Three, three.
One.
Oh, look, we're next to each other.
One, two, three!
Three!
pink space so grab me something from marshmallow okay is it
a group question from marshmallow oh yeah let's do a group
one so we can all answer something okay
okay okay guys we got a little marshmallow card what are
your favorite ice cream flavors favorite ice cream cream
should we do it in the in the tune of of the song i'm gonna
say yeah minchan hi
uh cookies and cream bibi
Hi!
What do you like?
Vanilla with rainbow sprinkles.
Oh, actually, if they have honey.
What?
If they have honey.
But not very many places have honey.
Hachimitsu Yorimo anada.
Oh!
Vicky, Hi!
Raspberry Ripple Yeah, I do like a bit of raspberry ripple I
love raspberry anything, yeah Yeah You guys have raspberry
ripple I don't know what that is But it sounds yummy What
about it is ripple?
Am I outing it as a British thing?
I don't know, like it's just nice It's very sweet And it's
got this bit of raspberry Going through it Raspberry ripple
It's very nice Yeah!
Like a kind of like a raspberry jam almost?
Yeah, it tastes a bit like raspberry jam.
And then I think it's like vanilla or milk or something like
that is good.
Oh, that sounds so yummy.
Sounds so good.
Oh, wait.
You guys know the pop and shower flavor at Japanese Baskin
Robbins?
Sh-shower?
Pop and shower?
Oh, I've heard of it, but I haven't tried it before.
It has pop rocks.
It's really yummy.
Oh, like shower, like a meteor shower.
or something, not like sweat and water.
No, this isn't Pekari sweat, but I love Pekari sweat
actually.
Wait, what about a shower makes you think of?
I don't know.
Like, if you think it's like shower flavored, it's like
water, isn't it?
No, I think it's like a star shower.
Like, it's like the star shower.
The very famous shampoo flavor.
I don't know.
Damn!
Wasn't that like a meme though in the VTuber community like
a long time ago?
Or like, what's your shampoo flavor?
I want to drink your shampoo.
Oh, really?
I don't know.
Am I wrong?
Am I too...
Am I... Mandela affected?
No, no, I just... I don't remember this, but...
I think... I think what kind of shampoo would I have?
I think it would smell like a... like a retro cafe.
I think it would smell like pudding and pizza toast.
Hopefully a non-smoking one.
Yeah, it just gives it a nice smoky flavor.
Smoked pudding.
Smoked pudding?
Interesting.
It's sophisticated.
Only grown-ups can enjoy it.
Oh, what about you guys?
Shampoo.
Okay, we know we should probably do another question first.
All right, we're getting into our own question.
Wait, save that.
is your question.
Save that one.
Yeah!
I don't know why we've returned to the star, but that's
fine.
I can move us back.
Okay.
Oh, oopsie.
You were over here.
And it's...
I was...
Over here.
Alright, Phoebe, it's time for you to roll!
Here we go!
Go, go!
What?
Five?
What's our five?
I think that...
three four uh i think that says back back to the star back
to star i
went on a nice little walk i like going on walks yeah this
was on purpose for a walk and wrapped right back around oh i
just wanted to i missed you guys too much i had to come back
and say hi to you
Hi Phoebe What are you saying about us that we're not doing
very well, huh?
Is that what you're saying?
You know?
Who's saying that?
Yeah, yeah.
Phoebe said she should come back to the start to be with us.
Like, I'm coming back to the start.
I'm coming back to the start.
So near the start.
Oh, yeah, because we're all at the start.
You're saying that we should be way behind or right?
I mean, none of us are really progressing so far, but don't
worry.
That's about to change.
Because I'm about.
to do the best roll ever just you wait and see oh oh i'm
ready oh okay okay that might be we might be getting
somewhere okay hang on yeah isn't it where how many did i
get before i got one before so it should be on six on the
purple one again i think so wait yeah i think yeah yeah yeah
yeah Yay!
Okay, let me...
Purple!
Okay, nice!
Yay!
Purple is member questions again, I think?
Should we just do a marshmallow?
What do you think?
Yeah, we could do a marshmallow though.
Yeah, let's do a marshmallow.
I also have a question though.
Oh!
Let's do it then.
Let's do it.
How do you like your steak?
Oh!
How well done do you have your steak?
Actually, is it okay if I ask both of you guys?
this because I need to know.
Yeah.
We're going to be, like, hanging out a lot.
I need to know how you like your steak.
Are we going to be making steak a lot?
No, it just says a lot about a person.
Ah, I like medium rare.
Medium rare.
What about you, Vicky?
I also like medium rare.
Oh, we're so, we're so back.
This is...
This is why I love you guys.
This is why I love you.
You passed.
You passed the vibe check.
This is fine.
Okay, good.
What?
I was scared for a second.
Wait, Phoebe, you also like medium rare?
We're all the same.
We're all the same?
Oh my gosh.
Meant to be, guys.
Meant to be.
Yeah.
Yo.
Medium rare, the goat.
You know what I'm saying, chat.
Yes, yes, yes.
Well done, everyone.
We got the right answer.
Good job, good job, everybody.
Good job, team.
I wrote right answers to any of these questions except for
that one.
Phoebe is definitely a pinnate or a steak.
We've learned that much.
Mintos!
Whoa!
Six.
Damn!
Okay.
One, two, three, four, five, six.
Oh, it's a mint question, I think, from Marshmallow.
Oh!
All right, let me find.
Do-do-do-do-do.
Yes, that's my name.
Don't wear it out.
Okay, here we go.
It's been over a month since your last book recommendation.
Book with strange quotes.
Oh, I love books.
What does this mean?
Could we get a new one?
Uh...
Oh, real quick.
Welcome, Raiders.
Thank you so much for the ring.
Welcome, welcome.
Welcome.
I hope you had a good stream.
Thank you so much for being here.
Yeah.
Well, um, honestly, I've been like so busy to even read
anything.
Um, hold on.
Let me check if I had anything in my...
In my audiobooks.
Uh...
Yaoi.
Oh, I'm so old.
man yowie.
I wish.
You wish.
You can make those dreams come true, you know.
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
So they're not actual books?
Oh, sorry.
Go ahead.
They're books.
They're...
Well, I was listening to...
I don't know if I finished this one.
I don't even remember anything about it.
Oh, I do remember a little bit about it.
It was kind of bad.
It was called Hello Billionaire.
Oh.
Hello.
I will go look it up.
No.
Why not, Miss Mint Fandom?
What could there be in this book that we should not be
looking up?
It was, oh my gosh, wait, when we were together and Phoebe
was just like, I love cryptids.
And I was talking about the Mothman book that I read not too
long ago.
I got so excited.
I was like, oh, Mothman, I love cryptids.
And then...
Mothman?
Maybe I'll look up this.
Maybe I'll look up this book.
And Mint was like, hmm.
Maybe you don't want to look up this book.
Should I...
Oh.
Um...
I don't even, I think I'm, I, I feel so empowered on my own
stream to say these things, but then when I am, when I am
faced with my own, with my own actions, I get so
embarrassed.
It's like all of the, all of the staff are listening meant
they're all.
Look, look, any literature is literature and we will not
judge you for what literature you consume because at least
you read.
So well said, Phoebe.
So well said.
Don't, don't, don't, don't, don't, it's okay.
Should we move on, Min?
Should we move on?
I think we should move on.
I will give the person an answer.
I will say, I haven't been reading much Dojin lately, but
the next time I do, I will recommend something.
I'll tell you guys.
Send it to me, too.
DM me.
Yeah.
Send it.
All right.
Phoebe.
Wait, Book Club, I guess I will.
read it too oh oh dear you're like on top of my dice but i
think it's a four oh four it looks like a four yeah yeah one
two three four that appears to be a uh mint colored space
which i think means is that a is that a phoebe question from
marshmallow if it's any of our member yeah yeah okay so
phoebe question from marshmallow come it right up give me
one second thank you
Phoebe.
Okay.
Phoebe!
So something I've been meaning to ask for a while.
Ami and Ami discover a current huge Phoebe fan hit.
Were the lyrics in start again.
So I took a leap of faith with you in the Varsan story.
Blue.
Meant to be a hint.
Oh, are they just a happy coincidence.
Just a little potential curiosity I noticed pretty early on.
In Learning Ami was Phoebe and Klaus.
going for your songs would you like to answer this one yes
i'm very i'm i love geeking out about my own lyric writing
and songwriting process um yeah so i'm really happy happy
somebody noticed but there were a bunch of like so i wrote
start again and i put out my first album uh right before i
went on hiatus to join prism project and i wanted to like
hint as much as possible but first of it was just kind of
like for my own personal satisfaction because i was like i
want to commemorate this important time in my life um but
also i love to put referential stuff and like hints and like
meta stuff into my writing so yes that was on purpose and
also if you notice in the album art and the music video for
start again there's hydrangeas everywhere and amy's model
has like hydrangeas so specifically pink hydrangeas so that
was on purpose to kind of of be like hello Phoebe Hive come
find me please oh you're so poetic Phoebe you know like in
your in your debut as well like it's like your whole story
is a is a song you know what I mean yeah it's so poetic yeah
wait why does that make me want to cry your whole story is a
song that hold on I'm writing this I need to write this down
sorry I may have been I'm expecting uh I'm expecting
royalties to uh fund my shadow Timberlands thank you very
much you know what now you know chat when she opens up a
throne i think there's only 30 of them okay this is a total
tangent there was only 30 of them sold so you had to like be
there at a shop in the morning and i was like i ain't gonna
that ain't happening but was it in japan yeah in japan yeah
i wonder if you could find them on mercari i mean probably
for hundreds of dollars yeah but i'm gonna look also someone
might have worn You know what I mean?
Like, shoes.
I don't know how I feel about that, you know.
Wait, but they were only sold 30.
How do you get your size?
Yeah, there's a good point, actually.
Yeah, wait.
Did they custom make it to you?
I have big feet, so they probably wouldn't even have it.
Yeah, there's a good point.
I've never been.
Yeah, I don't know.
I think they would.
All right, guys.
Who's it?
It's me next, isn't it?
It's you.
It's all you.
Oh, dear.
Sorry, Phoebe.
I knocked yours.
One.
Great.
That was my punishment, apparently.
Right, okay.
Damn, she pushed me away.
Yeah, sorry.
We're all, like, all bunched up together.
Look at us.
Aw, I love you.
Yeah.
Wait, orange is staff questions, isn't it?
I think.
Oh, yeah.
Orange is a staff question.
Our first staff question.
That's exciting.
First staff question, what they asking us?
I'm intrigued.
Okay.
Here we go.
Oh, it's so cute, the little boxes.
Questions from staff, son.
What are your favorite and least favorite Japanese snacks?
Is this for the group?
Yeah, I think so.
Where do you go?
Well, I can go first if you like.
I've got my combo holder on like, you know, speed up.
So, seaweed flavored crisps.
that nori shio beautiful love a bit of that I like the like
the chopped cucumber and stuff with the with the miso miso
dip that's good I don't like anything umeboshi or those sour
umeboshi candies that you can get literally the worst thing
in the world why do they sell them get that away from my
face I'm glad you also don't like umeboshi I don't like it
either it's okay I also don't like umeboshi Yeah!
We had that medium rare steak and no umeboshi.
Heck yeah.
Wow.
We're sounding so American.
That's how I don't want them Japanese umeboshi and I want my
steak medium rare.
My steak medium rare.
I want my sweet tea, my medium rare steak and I don't want
none of that umeboshi.
How did I do it?
Good.
That was real good.
What about you guys?
What's your favorite?
And least favorite?
I think recently...
Yeah, I'll go.
Recently, I've been super into these, like, Japanese jelly
gummies called Kororo.
Oh!
And they're like...
It's like...
It feels almost like an actual, like, grape.
I get the grape flavor.
It's, like, super, like, jelly and, like...
Oh, I've seen those.
Recently they've come to the States, they've been selling
them at like Japanese stores in the States.
So I really recommend them.
They're super, they're such an interesting texture.
I love it.
What's the texture like?
It's like, it's almost like a gusher, but like it's, it's, I
don't know how to...
Yeah, can someone translate gusher for me?
I guess we gotta experiment or experience it.
Oh, a gusher is like...
Don't they have...
Well, to be honest, I never had gushers as a kid.
So...
Yeah, okay.
It's not even like it, though.
It's so strange.
It's like...
You know how sometimes you can get jellies where it has like
a...
I don't know how to describe it at all.
I'm going to bring it to you.
That's what we need to do.
We need to do like...
You guys need to show me all of the best American snacks.
And I will judge them.
I will judge them.
I wouldn't say gusher is a great American snack.
But it's not even, that's like the best way to describe it,
but it's not even close at all.
I just, I feel like you just gotta try it.
Kororo, everybody.
Kororo.
Yeah.
Kororo, yeah.
Kororo.
Go check it out.
What about you, Phoebe?
Yeah.
So for, for, for sweet stuff, I love pudding so much.
I want to try all the different kinds of pudding, but my,
uh, favorite but i've always dreamt of having the the giga
pudding the qui the massive one yeah the master yeah i wanna
sit and do my first uh what do they call the food eating
streams uh mukbang mukbang muck yeah mukbang i'm gonna do my
first mukbang stream with a giiga pudding but uh my favorite
pudding that i've had in Japan so far was one that they had
at like the Disney resort which is called the pudding like
it's the pudding because it is dude i mean like it is it is
that guy like he is the pudding like he's like that pudding
was the best pudding i've ever had i need to have it i mean
no cap right like disney um disney tokyo food actually so
good like the i know except for the churros oh really you
don't like the churros i'm so sorry the churros with all the
love in my heart in the world those churros were i didn't
think it was possible to make a bad churro there goes our
disney churro sponsors but everything else delicious
everything else delicious i don't think i had the churro at
japan disney before yeah i don't think i have either to be
fair bro i'm gonna i'm gonna wait who's rolling now i just
rolled yes so now it's Phoebe, ignore y'all.
I hate y'all as well, but don't work.
Oh, six.
Six.
Oh, there.
Oh, Min is...
Min is...
I'm powering the head.
One, two, three, four, five, six.
It's like a blue one, which I guess is member questions from
the marshmallow.
Okay, let me find you a Minto question.
Minto question.
okay let's see what we got oh it's a sweet question oh very
sweet two made mint I know this was a long time dream how
are you feeling right now about the debut also why did you
and Vibi Vibi Vibi why did you and Vibi the combined the
combined Vicky and Phoebe entity choose Nensatsu exe what's
the story behind the name anyway huge congratulations
wishing you the best of luck oh that's very nice thank you i
was feeling so nervous before the the debut like i because
it's it's for me i feel a little weird because i was like i
i oh i wanted to make it feel like a debut but also like a
normal stream at the same time makes sense yeah yeah just
like oh yeah We're just having fun.
We're just being silly.
Vee-bee.
Vee-bee and picky.
Picky?
Ow, I'm picky.
It sounds like like chee-bee versions of you guys.
I'm Vee-bee.
It's I.
I'm picky.
I might change my name, not gonna lie.
Anyway, anyway.
And my serious question, Minto.
and moisture oh no no it's all good but um yeah i'm feeling
i'm feeling like a million bucks right now i'm so happy yeah
i love you guys so much and oh my gosh febby's we we saw
febby's video before like we did some uh like uh what's the
word a rehearsal run through yeah practice run yeah and
vicky and i were crying at her video then and it made me cry
again I was like, I finished the video and I was like, how
was it?
And then all I hear is...
And I was like, oh!
Yeah!
Absolute cinema, I was bawling, man.
Like the beginning video is so good.
I mean, the whole thing, the whole thing was amazing, but
yeah, just incredible.
Absolutely incredible.
Yeah.
Well, thank you.
I think all of our debuts were very us, so...
They were very us.
us yeah as for the name dead sets to exe yeah do we want to
talk about that later i don't know when do we want to talk
about it i don't know we could do it we could do it if it
depends do we want to talk about do we want to talk about
the whole group the whole story about behind everything
later is that something we want to do we have more time than
we thought because yeah i know We could do the video and
then talk about it.
Actually, yeah, because it kind of all, we had the same
rationale behind that as we did about a bunch of other
stuff.
So, yeah.
Yeah.
Are you okay with?
Okay, well, sorry that we can't answer your question right
now, but we're going to answer it after.
Yeah.
The mystery.
They don't know what video.
They don't know anything yet.
They don't know anything.
We know something you know.
Mare, Mare, Mare, Mare, Mare.
Picky knows something you don't know.
You guys are going to be very excited.
I can tell you that much.
But thank you for the congratulations.
All right.
Thank you.
Frippy.
Yeah, sorry for actually rolling your dice.
It will roll again.
It's okay.
You can roll me whenever you want.
Wipeys get rolled.
Okay.
I think you might be on the same space as me.
Wait, let me move myself.
only over here yeah you are it's another it's another orange
question from staff oh we're together we're together very
sweet all right question from staff uh let's have a look see
staff son making sure to keep on track of what what we've
answered what we haven't answered yeah okay if you were to
pick the animal you'll most like what animal would Would you
be?
It's so easy for me.
What about you guys?
What's, what, what are you?
I, I thrive in just chilling in the onsen, right?
I'd definitely be a capybara.
Yes.
Oh my gosh.
Yes, yes.
I want Sanard of Vicky with an orange on her head.
On her head.
A mandarin, a mandarin.
In another life, I'm definitely a capybara.
I just know it.
Sitting in that onsen with, with my little hat and ribbon,
just like, I could see you turning into like a tomato You're
just sitting in there for so long Do you get like dizzy or
anything at all?
No, not really I'm very good with like hot water, hot drinks
They don't really affect me at all If anything, my body
thrives Like you know like hot yoga as well I did that
before And I know that makes a lot of people feel sick But I
can do it for like ages Yeah Wow, strong Feel different
Seriously I just like you Phoebe go ahead Phoebe um well I
mean a lot of people would think be right away right because
I do always keep myself busy like I'm always always busy but
I think I think well I see some of my community members
saying bunny ah do you think so because I actually haven't
I'm thinking real hard about this I I do greet my I get
really excited when my housemates come home and i like greet
them at the door kind of like a puppy and they take me on
walks sometimes but so maybe a dog but then like but then
also but i but people are saying bunny i don't know what
what is the what do you guys think i know this isn't really
an animal but like every time i see nishino flower and
umamusume i'm like it's phoebe oh yeah you've mentioned that
before like don't be mean to Phoebe I people always like
when it came out in NA they were like oh my god this horse
this horse is you hello and I'm just so cute anyway Minto
what about you Animal what would you be I've been called a
cat before but also I feel also I'm also like a bunny a
little bit I feel like cat kind of suits you though like the
slightly kind of like cute Sundare You know Wait Sundare
Wait wait wait Maybe Ninto has like orange cat energy Do you
know what I mean?
Oh no I know what you mean Make them cat the orange ones
specifically The orange ones They are the orange ones are
crazy I love them so much though they're so silly unlovable
mint is orange cat it is decided i know orange cat all right
what was that another one these dice are rigged all right
anyways all right here we go she was number one uh oh that's
another member question right i think yeah oh let me let me
put phoebe properly on the space now that i've moved as well
um okay member question i for for me i suppose for you for
me yeah let's see what we got in the vicky vicky questions
near vicky oh this is my first question whoa now let's have
a look wait i i i i've already seen it i've already seen it
wait what happened well i was just reading it yeah i was
reading it too hi Vicky congrats on the debut I'm so happy
for you and I wish you nothing but the best however there's
a very important question that I have to ask you and it goes
a little slightly like this can you feel life moving through
your mind oh it's like you came out for more yeah can you
feel time slipping down your spine oh you're trying to
ignore yeah Hey, Vicky, enjoy
it.
That was wonderful.
I said this before, right?
But, like, genuinely, I think we could do the best, like,
Tails, Sonic Knuckles, like, collab, or something.
Like, Phoebe would be Tails, Min would be Sonic, and I would
be Knuckles, and, you know, it would be great.
I don't know.
I don't know what we'd do, but we'd do something, you know?
We would do something.
We would.
I think it would be the, you're Sonic.
You're, so you give the Sonic.
energy, Minto.
It's a good thing.
Why are you sad?
I feel like Bibi would be a perfect Amy, to be honest.
Yeah, okay, she would, to be fair.
Amy is my best girl.
Yeah.
I do love her.
You got, you've definitely got Amy energy, for sure.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Cute.
All right, Minto.
Rup.
Oh, Minto is winning this by a long way so far.
Are you sure the dice are different?
One, two, three, four, five, six is purple!
Purple!
Which is...
Questions from us.
Oh, I...
Okay, from me.
I have one.
Oh, or you can...
If you have one prepared already, Vicky.
I don't, but I can think of one.
Um...
Anything.
I believe in you.
You're dying questions.
Okay.
Um...
Hmm...
Hum...
Okay, if we were all to take a...
You know, if you guys were to come to Japan, we would take a
trip to Japan.
Where would you guys want to go?
On a trip together.
Or it doesn't have to be Japan.
Could be another country.
Could be anywhere.
Where would you guys want to go?
Okay.
I have my question.
I have my answer.
by you Phoebe okay let's go let's go mint first you got an
answer where do you want to go together okay well you said
Japan so I was thinking Japan hold on let me make sure I get
the name of this place right actually Phoebe go ahead oh I
was gonna I was gonna say the name of my favorite the cafe I
took you to Vicky but but maybe I wanna maybe I want to keep
it keep it a little low key restaurants go viral on tick
tock and then all of a sudden you can't get in anymore that
was so cute though i love that place there was a cute
cottage core cafe with like a craft shop attached to it so
lovely but if not that then a hakone maybe oh that would be
nice yeah because i love um there's like a really really
nice open air museum there oh yeah and then there's like the
shrines and stuff i love going to shine we can go on the
smelly cable car there's a smelly why is it smelly because
it's like sulfuric so you go over the top of the sulfur bin
it smells like farts
whoever smells it dealt it yeah we should we should go what
about yeah we should um well my My unrealistic answer is
Antarctica, but we could totally make it, you know?
Wow!
I've always wanted to go!
Yeah!
We should go!
Is that where you can see the lights?
The northern notes?
Well, they only come out in the winter, but...
Well, they're easier to see in the winter, but going...
But the trips are for, like, pedestrians are only in the
summer and...
Like, late spring and summer.
So...
But it's not...
It's not impossible.
Well, I've got another suggestion kind of on that theme
where we could see the Northern Lights as well.
I want to go Lapland!
I want to go meet Santa!
Oh, Santa!
Yeah!
Yeah, I want to go have the ultimate Christmas experience
with you guys.
I think that would be amazing.
That would be so fun!
I have one more thing for the opposite of that.
What do you mean the opposite?
Well, that would be cold, and this would be nice and toasty.
But there's a new park that just recently opened in Okinawa
called Jungleia.
I want to try it.
Yeah, we gotta go to Jungleia.
It's an amusement park that's dinosaur themed.
And you get chased by a T-Rex.
I want to go.
That sounds so well.
I love dinosaurs.
Because chasing, being chased by a T-Rex.
sounds kind of oh yeah you're in a car and the t-rex like
chases after you oh my god like a giant animatronic it's so
awesome we need to go we need to go that sounds amazing okay
that was there are so cute small dinosaurs too yeah i know
you can pet the dinosaur yeah i guess phoebe would like
small dinosaurs it sounds like the kind of thing you'd like
little guys yeah
Talking of Phoebe, let's roll.
Let's roll.
Oh, oh, pretty good, pretty good.
Oh, oh, oh.
One, two, three, four, five.
That is our orange, which I believe is stuff.
Stuff question?
Stuff question.
Which one was marshmallow again?
Again, a lot.
Whichever?
What do you want to do?
Let's do group marshmallow, maybe.
Okay.
Yeah, I took group.
Show to a minute.
D-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d-d.
Bada, bada, bada, bada, bada, bada, bada, bada, bada, bada,
bada, bada, bada, bada, this is a good question.
Howdy.
Will you do a podcast-like thing?
It doesn't have to be a regular or have a five-star runtime,
but three goofy girls.
Yeah, what does that mean?
Three goofy girls being goofy about stuff is my favorite
kind of yashike.
Thank you.
That's also one of my favorite kinds of yashike.
I had an idea, right?
That radio show idea.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, actually what I want to do is I want to put together a
monthly radio show for us when possible and have different
corners.
So, like, let's look at people's fan art corner and then,
oh, this is user-submitted questions or like a Batu game
corner or an announcement corner and just different kinds of
like silly and serious corners and stuff.
awesome yeah maybe we can like introduce like uh music on
there as well we could be like a radio oh yeah that'd be
nice highlight some of our new favorites or maybe like
talented people in the community yeah that sounds like so
much fun but i'd love to do that with you guys yeah all
right i'm gonna roll hopefully not a one again this time oh
yes my my luck is changing I'm moving up in the world.
One, two, three, four, five.
I think I think I'm there.
Is that a member?
A member question, I think.
Yeah, a member.
Okay, let's have a look.
If I cheated, let me know, chat.
Okay.
If I win, you can say that it's rigged.
That's understandable.
Rigged, rigged.
Okay.
Let's see.
Member.
The Vicky.
Okay.
Let's have a look, see.
What is your relation to Sir Times New?
That yoga has been haunting my word for us since time
immemorial.
Did you know, chat, that Sir Times New is actually Michael's
dad?
Whoa.
Wraithing the son of V, Sir Times New?
Yeah.
You need to start drawing up the family tree, guys.
Wait, what is Michael's relation to you, then?
Michael is my butler.
Yeah, so...
Yeah, but he's related because he's also a Roman.
Um, just...
Oh, yeah.
Wait.
Okay, let me rethink that.
Okay.
let's say sir times new is the best friend of michael yes
best friend of michael and my uncle let's go with that uncle
yeah uncle that makes sense uncle sir times new my favorite
uncle the best uncle yeah he's that guy is everywhere i see
him all the time he's like the cool uncle speaks a bit like
this my uncle speaks a bit like this yeah yeah a bit like
this yes yes yes that It's a times new.
Alright, guys.
Minto!
Biddu, biddu, minto!
Yes!
Five?
Wait a second.
One, two, three.
Oh, no.
I undo those claps.
What is that?
No!
What does that say?
Hang on, I need to...
It says jump to end.
No, it doesn't.
Jump to end.
Go back.
Five!
No!
Three, four, five.
Oh, dear.
Oh, dear, Minto.
Zanin, Zanin, Zanin.
Purple.
I think that is what?
Group marshmallow?
Let's go.
Group marshmallow.
We can do group.
Yeah, we haven't done a lot of group ones.
Yeah, let's do it.
Let's do it.
Okay.
We make our own rules, everybody.
Whatever color we want it to be, it will be.
you want to accomplish together as an idol group.
We got lots of those.
So many things.
I know.
I feel like...
Do we list them all?
Yeah, are we announcing some of our dreams right here and
now?
Right here and now?
Right here?
Right now?
This is the perfect place, I think.
I think one of the things we really wanted as a three
Ambassadors of Akihabara was one of them.
Yeah!
Yeah.
That was one thing.
If we can spread Akihabara culture and fun times to the
world, that would be really, really awesome.
We'd love to do that.
What were some of the other things?
You guys can say some of the other ones.
I'm trying to think.
We definitely talked about wanting to have a tie-in with an
anime or a game or something.
Then Setsu-do AXE anime opening.
That would be so heckin' cool.
Yeah.
We can do it.
Another one that I like incorporating our lore and our story
into 3D lives someday would be really, really cool, you
know?
We want to have like an ongoing story thing.
Yeah, kind of like almost a stage play in a way.
You should stick around till later.
later chat if you want to find out about more of the story
of den sensei yeah what is the story yeah what's going on
any other things to add i mean yeah i think honestly like
just being able to to perform on more and more stages do a
world tour you know yeah we can do that that'd be so cool we
want to meet a lot of you guys everywhere yeah Yeah.
And spread Akima culture throughout the world.
That's our goal.
Yep.
Yeah!
That's just a few.
That's a few.
I know.
I'm trying to think of the document we wrote.
We have a whole document chat somewhere.
Yeah.
So many documents.
Yay!
Yay, yay, yay!
All right.
So I think that was...
Who landed on that one?
Minto.
Okay.
So now it's Phoebe!
Real quick, real quick, apparently I'm on an instruction
space.
I saw in chat, I can't see very well, but I think I'm on an
instruction space, so I need to go back or whatever what it
says.
Wait, I thought you were on the orange, really?
Are you on orange, I thought I was on the orange, too.
Yeah, you should be on, oh, the orange has an instruction,
uh-oh.
Oh.
What's it say?
Go back for, oh, thanks, chat, thank you.
Thank you for pointing that out.
That's really sweet.
Chat is like sabotaging me.
Thank you, chat.
That's really nice of you, chat.
How nice.
You know, I just realized when I made this, I didn't put
any, like, go forward.
I only put it.
We are only doomed.
Oh, my God.
My bad.
Sorry.
No, no.
Don't worry.
It makes it more fun.
Now we're more evenly spaced out, I think.
But it's still anyone's game.
I thought we would get through it too quickly.
So I was like, keep going back.
Keep going back.
I will roll from here.
Three for Phoebe.
One, two, three.
That is a Phoebe.
Phoebe question from the marshmallow.
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
What?
This, okay, this is an interesting one.
Miss Phoebe, as a bee, do you carry pollen or dust?
Wow.
Well, pollen is kind of a dust already, isn't it?
But, uh...
I'm, first of all, I'm not a bee.
I am a fairy.
And so I got fairy dust.
But maybe my fairy dust is comprised of something similar to
pollen because I'm a flower fairy.
Does it pollinate?
So, how?
Do I have...
Pollinate me, Phoebe.
Oh, okay.
What?
Wait.
Me too.
I...
Okay.
Here, I wiggle.
Wiggle my pollen on you.
If I shake you, will pollen come out?
Do not shake babies.
She's a baby!
I like the idea that when you shake your tush, it's just
pollen.
Yeah, yeah.
Beads do a thing called a waggle.
And the waggle is how communicate with each other but i'm
sure when they when they do the little waggle that like all
their little dusty comes off comes off their butt and their
legs and stuff their butts and their legs are just covered
and it's i'm not beating the baby allocation you said it
yourself i know i feel
like it's an appropriate time to uh move on what do you guys
say yes yes please
three three one two three oh it's another vicky question
okay let's see what we have here let me make sure i'm
keeping keeping track of all the questions all right let's
see what we um oh no i've had it hang on should we should we
do a mint question i feel like we've already had Two each,
me and Phoebe.
Do shimashou.
Well, okay, anyways.
I'll put one for now.
It's your turn.
That's okay.
All right.
I'll do one mine next.
Yeah.
Are you able to grant Min-O-F Phoebe your yokai powers?
We were just saying...
We were literally just talking about...
Or singing this.
Because it's like, we were talking about how...
with den zetsu sometimes we typo or it's like den den it's
like but the answer would be i mean i feel like you're gonna
find out some stuff shortly but what i will say is you know
we're all we're all mythical in some way aren't we guys you
know so i don't need to grant them yokai powers they might
have powers of their own yeah because oh have you guys
noticed you know I'm a yokai.
Mint is a...
Yulei.
And Phoebe is a...
I'm a...
Yosei.
Yeah.
So, look forward to what that...
What that means, chat.
But in the meantime...
Minto!
Me!
Oh.
That was funky.
Two.
Two!
Member question for Minto.
Okay.
Minto, Minto, Minto, Minto, Minto, Minto, Minto, Minto,
Minto, Minto, Minto.
Minto, Minto, Minto, Minto, Minto, Minto, Minto.
Oh, yes.
I think this is a good question.
Do you think Phoebe and Vicky amplify your freakiness?
Or do you try to keep it low-key around them?
Well, I did talk about my books earlier, but I was
embarrassed about my books.
No!
No, don't be embarrassed about the things you love.
I don't love them.
Well, it's like a love paper.
Huh?
What?
Maybe, maybe, maybe, I don't know, I think, you know,
eventually we'll all just be super freaks all together.
Yeah!
People like, yeah!
People have to spend a lot of time together, rub off on each
other.
That's very true.
That's true.
I feel like we all have our own brand of freakiness, you
know?
That's so true.
Yeah.
Freaky.exe.
I was going to ask what Jarvis...
Run it!
Oh god.
Execute program.
Freaky.exe.
I want to know what's in that program.
If it's a combined, combined all three of our freakiness,
I'm scared.
Anyways.
Oh gosh.
What could it be?
Phoebe!
Two.
Two for Phoebe.
Okay, it's something.
It's something.
I think that's...
I literally cry like a baby.
Yeah, I'm sorry, Phoebe.
One, two, three, four, five.
You're back, you're back to orange again.
What's orange again?
Staffs ask questions.
Dab sound questions!
I like the comment that Freaky.exe is some combination of
Sonado and Snake and Ocelot and...
What's inside there?
What could be?
What could it be?
I mean that basically just sounds like a Smash fan fiction
or something.
Yeah.
Like Smash Bros.
Where they smash.
What do you like more?
A manicure or a pedicure?
Oh.
I can answer this very easily.
We can all answer this.
23, 2, 1.
Okay.
3, 2, 1.
Pedicure.
Manicure.
Uncertain.
Oh.
Why manicure, Minto?
I crave the touch of someone who's by hand.
Lude handholding.
Okay, anyway, Mickey.
I mean, honestly, fair.
I mean, mine is a bit more simple in the...
I love reflexology.
Like, I love anything with my feet.
Like, I can have, like, a...
You know, there's, like, really intense massages on your
feet.
Like, they could do it, like, literally, level 100.
I'd be like, yeah, this is cool.
So other things that people say hurt, I'm like, yeah.
So anything on my feet, love.
So that's why I'd go pedicure.
Feet enthusiast.
I'm ticklish.
They, like, scrub my feet and it makes me laugh.
It also makes me laugh, too.
Yeah.
But, I mean, it's nice having fresh feet, I guess.
And then you put it on, like, a nice soft carpet, and then
it feels good.
Oh, yeah.
But like...
So nice.
Oh yeah, not manicure or pedicure for me.
It's pre-cure.
I love pre-cure.
So I saw someone say pre-cure in chat.
She's so real for that.
But really like, I think manicures are nice because you get
to show off your pretty nails afterwards to everybody.
But I kind of hate like when you have to get your cuticles
cut.
And then...
It hurts so much.
Like for pedicures, it's nice getting your feet massaged.
But it also tickles.
So it's like, oh, do I want my fingers to hurt or do I want
my feet to tickle?
Maybe I just like having pretty nails without the whole
process of it.
That's so valid.
I just do press-ons nowadays.
That's kind of becoming a popular thing, huh?
Press-ons.
Yeah, I think so.
And they're reusable, so I could just pop them off when I'm
done and then put them on again when I want to.
That is small.
Densetsu EXE.
Densetsu.
Like press-on nails?
Nailset?
Hello?
So cute!
Oh my god!
I want it.
Write that down.
Are you listening?
We would love them sets.
EXE nail set.
I want a pair.
Alrighty.
I think it is a Mia.
Let's go.
Five.
Okay.
One, two.
Am I on the same one as Minto?
Oh, you might be.
Yeah, I think so.
Oh, you caught up!
Yeah.
Ah, here I am.
Here I am.
It's pink.
So I think that's another...
Let's go with a group mushroom.
I think it's meant to be a member question.
But I feel like we want to do more group...
You can do a group, yeah.
You can do a group too.
Someone in the server just said written down.
Press on nails.
Yay!
Yeah.
MVP forever!
excited to see you guys debut are there any companies you'd
love to be sponsored by as a group
sponsored by like like like cool like do a collab with or
like sponsored by like like have them give us money
yeah i think is good should we go with a collab and then a
sort of you know like uh sponsor that we'd like as well.
Well, in terms of collab, I'd love for us, yeah, as I said
before, I'd love for us to do something with Sega.
That would be amazing.
That'd be my dream.
And as for sponsors, you know, if I can be sponsored by
Yorkshire Tea and get some Yorkshire tea every stream,
that'd be great.
If I could get free Yorkshire tea, that'd be amazing.
Yeah, that'd be my pick.
What about you, Minto?
It's not Yorkshire.
Yorkshire Shire is like going to the go into the Shire like
the Hobbits That's what I thought it was I'm writing it down
I'm writing it Wait no cheating No there's cheating for
future British quizzes Stop writing it down I erase it from
my brain I would like to try the Yorkshire tea What about
you um i would like to be sponsored by blue archive because
it's my favorite game my favorite uh mobile game i think
it'd be fun um but for a collab
oh okay there's like a there's a there's a cafe in akihabara
called jam akihabara or made And I would like to do a collab
with them where we you could go and get a menu or something.
Yeah, that'd be so cool That'd be so cool.
Yeah, densetsu menu.
I'd love that.
That's so cool What about you Phoebes?
In terms of getting sponsored, I'm just like I was like I
drink a lot of throat coat and I also have a lot of kpop koa
So ninjom?
I don't know
Yes, please.
Actually, maybe infold.
Because I love Infinity Nikki.
And also, my housemates love Love and Deep Space.
So, I don't really play Love and Deep Space with my
housemate.
We have a giant Raphael cut out in our house.
So if I could get them some free currency for their pulls,
that would be awesome.
But I think...
Item label.
For me, at least for me, for me, like, item label is a big
one.
I could see us having a whole, like, I don't know if you
guys know item label.
Do either of you two know item label?
I don't think so.
No.
It's one of my favorite companies.
They make peepees and wee-wees and all kinds of little guys.
Aww.
What?
Yeah.
I don't know what...
Pepees, wee-wees, pee-wees.
Oh, how do I explain?
Wait.
It just sounds like different versions of Phoebe.
Different things I can call you.
It sounds like inappropriate parts.
Oh, I am.
I got peepees and weewees?
Two different kinds of people.
Take a look at my peewees.
They like make little...
They have characters.
They're like little cryptid-like characters, and they do
like random boxes, and I'm saving some random boxes for an
unboxing stream soon.
I love them.
They're like little cryptids.
Pee-Pee loves peanuts and he commits crime.
And then the baby version is called a Wii-Wi-Wi.
And it doesn't know anything.
Item label?
This is what they're called?
Item label, yeah.
So one of my dreams is to have a collab plush.
Or like some kind of drop with item label.
You spell it like Wii-Wi-Wi?
Is it like, are they French?
Yeah.
Like
Wii-Wi-Wi-Wi-Wi-Wi-Wi-Wi-Wi-Wi-Wi-Wi-Wi-Wi-WiWiWi-WiWiWi-Wi.
Oh, they look like furbies.
Oh no.
Yeah, they look kind of like furbies, don't they?
They're legally distinct.
Oh, okay.
Oh no.
I'm loving.
They look like beefies.
And there's like diglets and mons and dinkles and sucklets.
They're amazing homies.
How many are there?
Well, anyway, if you love them, Phoebe, then we love them
too.
Oh, thank you.
Yeah.
I hope that you will come to really love them.
And then you'll understand.
And you'll also want to collab.
and sponsorship with them too.
Yeah!
Cool!
Also, you guys mentioned Gacha, so, uh, yeah, Umamusume
carrots would be, would be amazing.
Thank you.
You're right, you're right.
Carrots would be awesome.
Thank you, thank you.
Or Cookie Run!
What if, what if we had a Cookie Run Kingdom collab?
Cookie Run!
Happy run!
Look.
BTS got a collab with Cookie Run Kingdom.
We should have a collab.
We're there.
Yeah, we're there.
Crazy, crazy.
statement if bts could have gone where's our gone hey listen
listen bts mvp three letters you know oh oh yeah you know i
think side games is goaded i think side games is like a big
big one i'd also want to yeah yeah be so cool all right
everything they do is peak i know right Minto!
Minto!
Three!
Wait.
Wait, that's okay.
No.
What's it say?
No!
Go back!
Five?
Oh, I think it's just three actually.
I think it's three rather than five.
So you're lucky.
One, two, three.
Wait, that's funny.
She keeps going back the same amount of spaces she traveled.
Wait, no, I thought it was...
Wait, did I typo?
No, it says five spaces.
Oh, it says five?
Okay, that's very honest of you.
Very honest indeed.
there you go uh so that is member question for minto i think
let's find a question for you yes okay member question you
came into yep i'm good not that one this one oh yeah i'm
intrigued actually for this one yes yes have you you showing
the girls your metal gear cabinet i haven't i haven't oh
like the patchy slot machine that i have or i guess is what
they mean um actually though i since i'll be um since i will
be moving soonish i i will be um selling it
Oh, I guess you don't really have a...
Maybe keep it with a friend?
Well, I...
What the plan is to sell it and then, um...
Buy a new one once I'm...
Where I plan to move to.
Ah...
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
I mean, I feel like it's the contents inside, right?
That's the important part anyways.
You know?
Right?
Yeah, yeah.
It's just because it's like so...
Well, it broke a little bit in Last Transit.
feel bad if i didn't properly package it and it broke even
more so true true yeah so it will go i've already have some
people looking at it uh it should go to a good home i think
oh that's good yeah well sad to hear though but yeah it's
okay i'll just get another patchy slide wow yeah nice that's
okay Yeah, you guys will see it one day.
Oh, I'm excited.
I'm very excited to see it.
And I'm excited to play Metal Gear too.
I'm excited for you to teach me all about it.
I'm going to definitely play you at some point.
Yeah, I'm going to play.
I'm going to play.
I want to try.
Okay, do I play or do I just watch Vicky's playthrough
event, I wonder?
Neither.
Yeah, you could play together.
Yeah.
Actually, that could be a thing.
It could be.
I mean, to be fair, I'm awful at like stealth games, so you
might need to help me to be honest.
the stealth parts Legend of Zelda Wind Waker taught me a lot
about stealth or Zelda games and gel taught me about stealth
I like how you said the stealth parts when the whole game is
a stealth game so basically I don't think I'm going to be
very good BB play yeah alright for B let's roll we got a 3
okay and then probably we'll do like one more round and
whoever's the whoever's furthest long as the winner should
we say yeah yeah okay we got three okay let's let's do just
group questions from here on out then get a few get a few
group ones in but maybe we can bring this back at some point
you know like we have a lot more questions thank you it was
like 350 or like almost 400 questions really wow what that's
so nice thank you guys so much thank you Thank you!
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Who are your favorite Umas?
Who are your favorite Umas, everybody?
I'll go first.
Oh, yeah!
Mejino McQueen.
Wait, you also said you like, uh...
You like, uh...
Oh, uh...
Ocondor, what?
Yeah, Ocondor Pasa!
Ocondor Pasa, so cute!
Yeah, she's so cute.
She was my first favorite, so I still have a, like, a soft
spot for her.
Wait, so is it Mejino McQueen?
the queen has she overthrown has the queen overthrown
al-kondor pasta i may have oh she hand yeah i may have
committed the sin i'm sorry i may have umahend umahend
that's crazy it sounds like you're just using osaka bed like
saying something's delicious like umah umahend What about
you, Phoebe?
It's really hard for me to...
I honestly think my number one favorite is still Rice
Shower.
But real close seconds are...
I actually really, really like and relate to Smart Falcon.
And then, of course, I love Haru Udara.
She's a really close second, too.
Ah, Haru Udara.
And then...
Everyone says that I'm like Nishino Flower, but she's not...
in the game yet so i don't really know her that well um but
maybe she'll become a she'll come up there too i'm sure she
will honestly she yeah every time she comes up i'm like it's
baby i'm saving a slot for her ah so sweet i like i like
silence zuka i like vodka i like ogri cap i like kawakami
princess those are my top four but i have many others and i
should do a tailor at some point on my second free roll of
the day I got Agnes digital in two roles Wow you got your
luck on your side no I've got crazy luck in that game
honestly all right last round of questions okey-dokey who is
gonna be the ultimate winner okay one two three nice avoided
avoided going back just a i think vicky number one actually
came yeah i hope so i hope so um okay any chance of doing
some vocaloid covers question to the group?
I think so.
Yeah, we were all nodding.
Never say never, you know.
We'll probably do lots of different kinds of covers.
So, yeah.
I think we all grew up on Vocaloid too.
So, we have a lot of possibilities.
There's just so many songs I want to sing with you guys.
I feel like there's a lot of Vocaloid songs we can do, you
know?
Do you guys have a favorite Vocaloid song that you'd like to
cover as a group or you'd like to cover yourself?
Well, I see a lot.
A lot of people, some people were saying triple baka when we
started teasing.
Oh, yeah, that's right!
Come on, come on, come on!
Oh!
That would be fun!
That would be so fun!
It's so our energy as well, that song isn't it?
We should, like, create a channel where we just suggest
putting songs that we want to cover together so we can
always reference back to it.
Yeah!
It's a good idea.
Watch, we're gonna go to the server and then they're gonna
have already made that channel for us.
I don't know why I sound like a chicken then.
Anyway, minto!
Three!
I'm back where I...
Back where you were before!
Awesome!
Yeah!
Doggy doggy.
Would you consider playing or singing songs of Project Six
Man?
There's a lot of like Vocaloid fan.
Yeah, lots of Vocaloid people.
Singing songs of Project Sekai together in the future.
I think if Momo Jump was real, they would definitely be your
co-hies.
Do you guys have some more like background on this?
Because I haven't played Project Sekai.
I've always been interested to try, but...
I love...
I love Nui Eji idols by more and more Jump.
I could see us singing something like that.
I don't play it either, but I know so many of the Sayu in it
that I check out the song.
sometimes.
Yeah, Ogurayui's in more and more jump.
We love Ogurayui.
She is.
She's like the main girl, Nuri.
Oh, wait.
I think I did, though, that I...
Yeah.
I forgot.
I just don't play it.
I've always wanted to try it.
So maybe this is my opportunity.
I will check it out.
Thank you very much for your question.
And final roll.
Will Phoebe get...
Like, 25.
Roll all three.
and then add them together.
Really?
Yeah, for some extra drama.
Okay, here we go.
Oh, my God!
13!
Done.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten,
eleven, twelve.
Oh, well, that's nice.
You guys love the same spot.
Oh.
That's so nice.
Why do I feel like crying for real right now?
Aww.
I'm so happy.
It was fate.
It was both.
It was definitely fate, you guys.
And you guys can do, you guys are both the same place and
you can do the Batsu game that I have prepared together.
Wait, wait.
You already have something that you already know.
Wow.
You were the one that didn't want a Batsu game.
I know.
What was this for?
Stop!
Isn't that nice?
guys isn't that nice question which of you would win if you
all had an arm wrestling contest that's what a great
question to end on i think it would be you vicky because
you're the one talking about lifting us both yeah you do
training yeah i i think you i feel bad saying me but i think
me i really think so i think so too yeah people call me
noodle arms so you know I like do small little, like the
little weights.
You know what I mean?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Nice, nice, nice.
She wins in the game and she wins in the armrest.
I hope you guys are excited for me to lift you guys someday.
Someday, someday.
I'm so excited.
So excited.
I want to do the like nobody puts baby in the corner where
you guys like run from the other side of the room that I
lift you up and spin you around.
Perfect.
It's going to be great.
And with that, we have the winner announcement.
The winner is me!
And your Batsu game, guys.
Next time you are both on holiday in Japan, I have some very
nice omiyage that I bought recently at the Wasabi Farm.
It's a wasabi long the shab biscuits.
I thought, oh, they might be nice.
There wasabi and white chocolate combined together.
They taste like some kind of funky weird cheese.
They're like the, no, no, no, no, you don't understand.
They're like, they're really, really bad guys.
So you're gonna have to eat one of those each.
No!
Are you sure?
I'm holding your, I'm holding your, your shadows hostage.
No!
No, give me my shadows!
We'll make a deal.
We'll bargain.
I'll...
I'll actually...
I kind of want to try it, though.
I kind of want to...
You said it's like cheese.
I like cheese.
No, no, but bad, bad cheese.
Like, cheese has gone off in the back of the fridge.
Like...
Oh, the back of the cheese fridge.
Bad.
Yeah, it's...
It ain't good, Phoebe.
But it...
Is it spicy?
No, not really.
It was just a weird combination.
I thought it would be nice.
really wasn't so you guys are gonna have to eat them oh if
it's not spicy i'll try okay well that's your batso game so
i'll keep you guys updated well next time we're all in japan
together i will give you guys those and you will have to eat
them okay i'm excited wait i don't know yeah i don't you
shouldn't be you really shouldn't be but with that it's our
game you guys it's now time for What are we gonna do?
What are we gonna do?
Are we saying?
Are we saying it?
What are we doing?
Yeah, it's a good question.
Which one are we doing first?
Someone tell me.
We were gonna do the...
Well, we're gonna do the...
Wait, should we do the video first or the song?
Yeah, I think the video.
I think the video.
Oh, oh, oh, you're right.
Sorry, I forgot about...
I forgot.
Don't forget!
Don't forget.
Um, yeah.
I think the video, the video.
Everybody wanting to learn more about Densitude EXE, we will
talk more about it.
After this, messages.
After these messages.
Yeah, these messages.
These messages.
A sneaky video.
Alright, see you guys in a bit.
Doza!
I'm sorry guys, but the chicken flavor definitely wins.
No way.
The shrimp flavor is peak.
I don't know.
I think the beef is really tasty.
I still can't believe how much we actually have in common.
Right?
Plus, we're the dream team!
A yurei, a yokai and a yosei...
its cafe has been so lively ever since.
And how we all came together because we wanted to form an
idol group?
It has to be fate.
I just know it.
Do you guys really think we can stop this place from being
demolished?
It's gonna take a lot of work, but if we stick to the plan,
I know we can save it.
Right, Phoebe?
Mm-hmm.
From my time as a solo idol, I have learned that you can
accomplish anything with enough determination.
It'll lead into our paychecks for a while, but it's a small
price to pay to bring this place back.
Don't worry about it, Mint.
This once-thriving May Cafe in the heart of Akihabara will
live again.
Then let's give it everything we got!
Yeah!
Sunday!
Tonight's the big night.
You guys ready?
I'm working on closing the cafe right now.
I'm so nervous.
Excited, nervous!
I'll be leaving work soon too.
I'm so excited!
Good.
Let's make sure to channel all of that into our show.
Yay!
Running there right now!
And in recent news, there have been growing concerns over
more missing persons in the Akihabara area.
Four more people have suddenly vanished without a trace.
Officials are advising individuals to remain indoors as much
as possible, especially during the evening.
I'm your blossoming fairy, Sidi.
Don't lose your head.
I'm your yokai princess, Victoria Roman.
My, my boo!
I'm your haunting ghost maid and maid phantom!
And together we are...
Yure!
Yokeai, you!
Me?
Be a part of our story!
We are Tencent to Goi EXP!
We
are so cooked!
The whole moon has been saved.
How'd you guys find it?
Did you like it?
Oh my gosh, we're your Akiba Protector's Densetsu Yaxi!
Yay!
We wanted to just be an idol group, but it seems that
someone has to defeat some evil force that's going through
Akihaburo right now.
So we took on an extra piece of our job description.
Yeah, just a little bit.
Just a little bit.
Just a bit.
Hmm.
Idol demon hunters.
That's us.
Yay!
J-pop demon hunters J-pop demon hunters love it but no
wasn't it so well put together I love the video yeah what
was your guys favorite bit I liked when we were like we're
so screwed yeah we are so screwed So quick!
Yeah, that bit's pretty good.
I also like, um...
I like the bit with old dancing, like the shitty little
chibi.
Oh yeah, the chibi's are so cute!
Yeah, I love that!
Yes, so I'd be cute!
Love that thing.
I thought all the, like, anime cameos were really, really
fun.
Oh yeah, yeah.
Um...
I don't know if anybody noticed, but we kind of, like, it's
kind of in the style of some, like, older anime and... or
different various different kinds of anime um that's
something we had specifically asked for so great job to the
animation team thank you so much for your hard work thank
you uh i think i i assume that'll be uploaded to the group
channel at some point at a later time uh separately if you
guys want to watch it and check it out but we had such a
great team great team working on it and yeah i mean i'm sure
you guys felt the same when i when i saw it for the first
time my jaw hit the floor like so cool so thank you our
little lore our story yes be part of our story that's
something else did you guys notice we have a call-in
response yeah whoa should we try and do it together or is
the lag oh the lag by the i think the lag will make it
better okay guys minto do you want to want to tell the chat
what they need to do okay so basically we're gonna say you
and you guys say me and when we say be a part of our story
we are densetsu.exe yeah yeah basically nice to be sad me
yeah and you just said to that exe and yeah so basically
densetsu in japanese is legend you know We are all three of
us.
We're all legendary creatures with Yokai, Yure, and Yosei.
So we're creating our own legendary, our own Akihabara
legends together.
So, yeah.
We want you to also join us on our story.
Let's try it, chat.
Are you ready?
Yeah.
Are we doing three, two, one?
Oh, gosh.
Are we?
Is it...
I'm cooked if we're clapping.
What was the order again?
Was it...
was it...
Yurei...
Yosei...
Yokai?
Yes.
Okay.
Just making sure.
We're getting this down too still, you guys.
We're getting this down too.
We're figuring it out, yeah.
Shall we?
Yes.
Oh, I go first then, right?
Eure.
Yosei.
Yo-kay.
You.
Me?
It sounds so confused.
Be a part of our story!
We are...
Jensen to the ESG!
Actually, incredible.
Well done, chat.
You did great.
Yay, good job, everybody.
Me?
They did great.
Us, on the other hand, we might...
You know.
So yeah, that's how we came up with our name.
we are we are all legends we are all legends and we wanted
it to sound kind of akihabura-esque to match our aesthetic
and that's how we came up with densetsu.exe yeah yeah yes
yeah and then also a part of our the start of our legend is
a song maybe a song do you guys want to listen to densetsu
mvp Do you guys want to listen?
Do you guys want to listen?
I know you want to listen.
Now, we will say the video is not...
There would be no visuals this time.
There will be.
We are going to have them for today.
Are we saying what there will be?
No, not...
We could just...
Are we...
Ta-da!
Are we Tadaring?
Which one are we Tadaring?
What are we Tadaring?
Sorry, I was looking at the preview.
We can say it.
We can do it.
Let me Tadar a second time.
I'll redo the Tadar.
Am I Tadaring?
What I am Tadaring?
Is that good?
You can Tadar.
Music video will be released this month but since you guys
are all here today.
Special treat.
yes going down listen we're probably not we want you guys to
listen to it fully so we're just gonna we're just gonna vibe
and dance while we're listening but looking forward to it i
hope you guys will hekin love it as much as we do because
it's it's amazing all right let me just get everything set
up okay and then we have one more announcement right after
this as well so stick around stick around yeah yeah
okie-dokie okie-dokie here we go we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna be silent silent for for the anthem of denser so
exe here we go let's go
Let's head together to electric town I'll swing on over with
you Oh, what a thrill to be by your side There's nothing we
can't do Hey!
You are the MVP Take off all our new time
Don't be afraid Don't you look into panning each and
everyone Let's go Let's go We're the same way
We're the same way Painting the future we seek Never stop
your dreaming I think colors will light the stage Fill the
world with
MVP Let's
fight, ready to feel the beat Voices ready to shout along
One, two, three For you Science Show will be me I'm your
flower fairy Phoebe We're
done?
How can I serve you?
Would you like food?
Or a bath?
Or maybe a scary story?
I'm here to go
I'm here this comfy little world We're in here with you They
would have it almost like it's magic Come with me
It's just so we guys think Yeah, what did you guys think
about it?
Guys, everyone's so excited.
Thank you!
It's truly Kami KyoKu.
It's such a good song.
It's everything, honestly.
Aneta-san, thank you very much.
Thank you.
Aneta-san, the goat, honestly.
Yeah.
Do we want to go through like our thoughts on the song, each
of us?
Go ahead, Phoebe, if you've got your comment together.
Oh, I can go.
Well, I'm not sure, like...
Oh, you go first.
I don't know where to start.
No, I just...
My favorite bit, I have so...
many favorite bits um in in this in this song i i love it i
truly love it so much um but my favorite bit is definitely
the bit that leads between our different types of singing
voices so you've got yes the swing uh kind of like jazzy
jazzy bit with me yeah because we all know how much you know
i'm in the red dress doing that jazz it's like chef's kiss
you know uh and you know and then I've got me doing kind of
Enka rock style and then Phoebe with the kind of Fujikaze
style R&B coming in there.
I feel like that shows our personalities so well and that's
definitely my favorite bit.
I also love the call and response parts and I just, I can't
wait to do it live with you guys too, you know?
Right!
And then Anika, thank you very, very, very much.
I mean, I feel like a lot of our favorite parts, I mean, the
whole thing is very good.
The melody is very, very, very, very, very, very And there
were a few things that we really, really wanted to have in
the song.
One of them was, like, as per a lot of DEMPA songs, a lot
of, like, crazy kind of, like, changes within the song,
whether it's Campo changes, key changes, genre, even
freaking genre changes.
The genre changing part feels so, like, both cohesive and
it, like, showcases all of our, like, individual strengths,
too.
And I think that's something really, truly beautiful about
our group that Aneta-san was able to like capture so well.
By the way, I have something a little bit more about the
demo Aneta-san sent us to say in a little bit.
But like, really, we're all so different and yet similar to
each other.
We're all very, very unique.
And yet we are united under a single shining dream.
grateful that I get to chase my dreams now with such
precious friends and talented collaborators and Anita San
really like captured that a lot in fact it was funny because
in the demo that he sent us he actually had like sung it
himself and then formatted his voice to like sound a little
bit more feminine but then you could tell that he had
specifically you could tell which parts were meant for who?
For which person?
even though it was just like placeholder lyrics at the time
because he sung he like tried to mimic each of us yeah there
was a part the original the original talking part that was
like victoria no man or something like that honestly could
release the secret anna to sand version i'd loop that it's
so good his voice is actually amazing i love his voice but
um something i want point out real quick.
I'm sorry.
You guys need to shut me up because I can talk.
I'm going to talk about it.
Talk!
Yeah!
In the talking section.
Why do I feel like I'm going to cry?
Why do I...
In the talking section.
Something really cool.
When I get really excited, I stop being able to breathe.
Hold on.
In the talking section, there are solos playing in the
background.
Instrument solos going in the background of each of are like
talking parts but anita san changes the solo and also
changes the instrument playing it playing in each section
too so vicky has like a a piano solo and minto has like this
like a guitar synth thing going on and then i have like a i
need to go back and listen to it but you would have to
listen to the instrument i think you have the guitar synth i
think i have a saxophone you have a sack yeah you have a
saxophone i have like a guitar synth vicky has a piano and
they're they each sound a little different so there's like
little like shimmery fairy sounds in my part and then in
Vicky's part it's like wow like that yeah that's actually
our voices yeah do you guys like a wow um very yokai like
and then spooky little spooky little mental sounds and so
it's really like but it all comes together so cohesively
right like it doesn't sound like a mess at all so it's like
there's a there's a yeah like our three colors will light
the stage three very distinct colors all coming together to
make something beautiful that's us that is the essence of
densetsu.exe right there right there oh freebie also i want
to say too like we did all write the lyrics together in some
way but i think phoebe did most of it so thank you phoebe
yeah thank you phoebe
I think I got a little too gung-ho.
I ended up writing lyrics for the entire song.
And I was like, I hope they don't feel like I'm being bossy,
like coming in and having a full draft.
Because we were like, we're going to meet at this time,
collaborate on the lyrics.
But basically what happened was I brought it.
And then you guys changed some parts.
And like, you know, the parts where you did the solos with
the genres and stuff.
You changed a little bit of that.
like give you a nice touch to it but i i i was a little
worried at first actually i was like oh i hope i'm not
forced i really hope i'm not forcing no it was just that no
your ideas were we looked at them we were like that's
perfect yeah exactly yeah i think yeah what's also insane is
just how little time we had to put this all together we we
basically we received the song like and then we but that was
like the weekend that um mint and i were doing things for us
idol fest so it was yeah yeah it was like so much going on
yeah rush of just everything so um but yeah it was just it
all came together and we kept some of the japanese lyrics
that um anita san wrote for us as well yeah we were just so
good yeah the imagery was like really really nice so we we
should we could get like a translation of them and include
it with the lyrics so people that would be a nice idea yeah
so um it you know i've never written lyrics before so i came
in and i was like oh does any of this sound good no i love
the ideas we all we all gave ideas you know and they helped
to shape the final product truly yeah so i'm so proud of us
yeah i know I first heard the song I just like was bawling I
was like this is exactly like I don't know I yeah I was like
I love you know Dempa style with like the genre changes and
everything and it just felt like very you know I would kept
describing it as like so like fun and emoy at the same time
like it's it's seriously just like a super fun song and I
hope everybody listens to it lots and lots and
month the music video so i hope you guys will give it lots
lots of listens loop loop loop it yes just so so happy and
excited for us and yeah please fall in love with the song as
much as we did i love you i love you i love you uh mvp
forever mvp forever now
if you guys also want to rep uh MVP forever!
Oh!
We have...
Well, maybe too early for a drum roll.
Uh, we have...
Wait, uh...
Oh, oh...
Guess what did it guys!
Can we go over to the screen?
Can you guess what we're gonna announce?
Yeah, what do we have?
What do we have, guys?
What do you think?
Actually, what's actually two announced?
It's actually...
Is it?
It is.
Vicky's on like a different wavelength than Vicky.
No way, no!
The thing that Vicky's scrambling to prepare right now.
Yeah.
And then there's also...
There's also...
Also?
Something else that is...
Can you tell us?
That is gonna start really soon.
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
Oh!
Yeah!
That, that.
I put it in the chat.
Yay, yay, yay, yay.
Okay, we...
Yes.
yes yes oh yeah that thing that thing that thing we are so
we are so screwed i feel i feel like that you know you can
really tell how me and mint both showed up for the wrong day
of a concert i remember telling that story and then i later
on i was like oh my gosh say it was vicky it was me and
victoria we were trying to go to a concert together and then
both of us were like okay we'll meet up on this day we'll go
oh dear anyways should we should we do this one first get a
drum roll what do you think we could do this one yeah yeah
yeah oh
now i know my What is it?
And it's the...
Oh yeah, that's good, that's good, that's good.
I don't have the tools you guys have.
Oh my gosh, you guys!
We have...
Patreon!
This is our fan club!
Our little fan club.
So basically, every month you guys are going to get to enjoy
some really, really special goodies from us like what so
there's gonna be different tier so it's first of all this is
starting in january it's starting in january some of you
guys were like oh i get paid next week that's okay and the
holidays are happening too um you're gonna get some holiday
money hopefully and then our subscription is gonna start in
january um so exciting yeah oh my gosh and Look forward to
the things that we'll put out and everything in the Patreon.
We already have some very nice artwork in the works and
stuff.
Yeah.
So, that's a fun thing.
Let's see.
Well, basically, what do idols, what is like the big selling
item when you go to an idol live?
I wish I had a picture to commemorate my experience.
Maybe with a signature or a little doodle from my...
Oh yeah, yeah, it would be so nice.
Wouldn't that be nice?
Yeah, something to commemorate.
Yeah, I just want to take pictures of food with that thing.
Yeah, yeah, right.
Maybe meshy with that thing.
Yeah, meshy.
Meshy with it.
No, it's a checky.
Yeah!
So that's one thing.
With art from different artists we really want to like help
celebrate the community and how talented everybody is and
it's so we're gonna be we are sourcing artists from the
community to rotate on a monthly basis yeah we've already
seen some of them and they're so cute so yeah so look
forward to the stickers really cool stuff from amazing
artists alongside the Chekis.
They are monthly rewards and there will be different tiers
as well.
Yeah.
Very cool.
What else?
Basically, you're going to be...
Yeah, so there's... Yeah, I think you have stickers,
postcard, Chekis.
There are different various rewards depending on the tier,
but any kind of support towards the fan club directly
supports our activities as an idol group.
So you guys can like... There's Some big stuff we're trying
to cook up next year.
Some big stuff.
And it sure would be nice if you guys wanted to us to be
able to make some more big stuff.
So that's what you'd be supporting is us making big stuff.
Little guys making big stuff.
Big stuff.
Thank you so much for supporting our idle dreams.
And if you are able to join the Patreon when it opens in
June.
January it would be very much appreciated thank you so much
thank you thank you thank you and thanks to the amazing
artists who uh who have been working already on art for our
goodies for you guys some of you may be watching this you're
amazing the art's beautiful so far so cute this is and i'm
just gonna quickly check okay oh okay good all right we're
good to go We're good to go.
Announcement two.
Electric Boolalo!
Yeah!
Merge!
We've got merchandise.
Check out these beautiful can badges of the lovely Kink Mama
arts.
I want you to make this filled.
Eat a bag with them.
I want to make an eat a bag of everyone.
Yeah.
What have we got next?
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
We also have individual stannies of each member.
So cute.
Oh my god, wow!
I love how the logo, our logo is the stand, like the base.
It's so nice!
It's the best!
I love it!
You can show Phoebe's.
Oh,
really cute!
Kira, kira, kira, kira, kira.
Kira, kira pose.
Oh, cute!
Look at the floof in this corner.
So pretty.
I know.
I love it like the shiny kind of Akihabara lights as well.
while on the cape is so pretty yeah yeah love it and you
know when you think hmm you know i've got those checkies
from the fan club what am i gonna do with the checkies yeah
where do i put where do i put yeah i'm gonna have all these
checkies yeah i'm gonna stick them on the wall no i need
somewhere to collect them collect them together Oh
Oh Oh my gosh Customized to each of us This is the baby wine
The baby The baby wine So pretty and the minto Wow So cute
So beautiful And then we also have This next one is Pim.
The next one is everything.
Honestly, this...
I want everything, but this one.
This one.
Yeah, this one is our favorite.
Oh, what is that?
What is that?
Oh, my God.
No one expected.
What is that?
Yeah, what could it be?
I think I read.
recognize the back of those heads, I think.
Yeah, they look very, very like I've seen them somewhere
before, you know?
Something about them.
I gotta see the front!
You gotta show me!
I gotta see it now!
This special little headband that you can customize with the
three of us, as well as we will be selling the, just the
heads.
So, you could create a headband full of Vicky!
Oh, our Phoebe, full of Vito, or just full of all three of
us all together.
Or you can just walk around your house.
Or you could just get the head.
You could put it on your belt.
You could put it on your shoulder.
Let's collect our heads.
Yeah.
Do it.
I'm going to yeet my Vickies out of the window.
At random passes by.
No, I'm not going to do that, but you could do anything you
want.
They would be so honored.
They'd be like, no way.
Victoria Roman.
From the sky.
Come on, just the hedge.
And it's, you know, a dream for us to do live shows together
at some point and that sort of thing.
And if we're doing a live show, you know, what do you need
if you're doing a live show as a fan?
Yes.
You need the heads.
Also.
Don't lose your head.
Also, what do we need?
I'm happy.
I
got it.
Zoom.
Magnify.
Magnify?
Yes, yes.
Jarvis.
I can.
Can you see?
Can you see it?
I see it.
Whoa.
Wow.
Look at the comments in Nico niko doga style all on the
back.
Wow.
It's so beautiful.
Yeah, I love the niko niko doga sell comments.
Oh, link is pinned in the chat by the way.
Oh, link is pinned if any of you guys wanna go snip it right
now.
It's no lie.
Oh.
It's love!
You can probably see...
Wait, are the pictures better?
Yeah, the Tamaku text, right?
Yeah, the Tamaku text!
Oh yeah, the pictures are much clearer on the site, so...
Yes, sorry, that might be my setup.
That's okay.
Please, Jai Jobu.
Go have a look, guys, the different offerings that we have.
How exciting!
I mean, this alone is like a dream, isn't it?
A merch draw?
I know.
Right?
So cool.
I want to wear it.
I'm excited to buy everything.
Me too.
I'm getting five of the head, but I'm going to cover my body
in little heads.
I'm just kidding.
That's like a Dark Souls boss, the collector of heads.
Right there.
Grafted.
Yeah, Grafted Elden Ring boss, but it's just those little
guys.
Oh my gosh It's so beautiful Oh guys How are we feeling that
I'm just I'm so Feeling so full of happiness You know Like
Yeah So many great announcements Got the song coming The
music video release happening this month Got the merch
that's now live How are you guys feeling about everything?
Heartful Heartful Brinful Yeah Flatter getting there Yeah
Yeah Fair I've also been drinking a lot of water Good Get
your bottle of water Chat But no I just I just want to take
this opportunity To say How much I love you girls And I'm so
excited For what we're going to achieve Together Um I did
genuinely think both of you are like so so talented um in
your different ways like you got such beautiful voices both
of you like different styles but i feel like when our styles
combine is truly the makings of something magical and you
know we've been something legendary yeah yeah but yeah i'm
just so excited for this journey with you both so thank you
Yeah, it's really...
I don't know, I...
I've been also very grateful.
It's been a long time since I've been in an idol group.
And...
And I...
And even...
It's been really fun doing solo stuff.
And I'll keep doing that too.
But like...
I think...
I didn't think that I would find people that I like resonate
with on this level.
Ever.
I was like, I'm just gonna do solo idol stuff forever.
But...
It was very lonely.
I was lonely.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I was lonely and I'm so...
I feel like...
So, so happy to have you guys in my life.
You guys and our wonderful communities.
And...
And so many wonderful people, like everybody that came
together to make this happen, the Setsuna team, the people
that came together to make our debuts as beautiful as they
were.
Like, so many wonderful friends have come into our lives
because of this.
think it was possible to not be lonely anymore so so thank
you thank you for it
we just want to hug you right now i'll grab your head
please you you owe me you guys owe me you owe me we owe each
other big big hugs next time we see each other absolutely
yeah came together in a in a sort of unconventional way but
you know I feel that we're we're a super great team together
and we have we have big goals and we have big hearts so I
think you know no matter what we accomplish I think it's
gonna be a lot of fun no matter you know it's all about the
journey and making you know making our own story so I'm I'm
really excited to see what kind of things we do create so
and with everybody together too so thank you everybody for
being here and watching us and supporting supporting all of
us and we're really excited about what we get to create for
all of you so thank you very much for giving us the
opportunity as well yeah guys just all right group hug group
hug group hug group hug group
hug Yeah!
Yeah!
We can do this thing!
We got this!
It's gonna be so wonderful.
It's already wonderful!
Seriously, chat, you need to look forward to everything
we're cooking because we're cooking.
We're chefs!
We are... we're chefs!
Ah, cook with the spaghetti!
I mean, there is so much spaghetti that you haven't even
seen yet, chat.
So much we're cooking already, you know, so, yeah.
And stream Dentsu 2 MVPs, lots and lots and lots!
When it comes out.
Yeah, when it comes out.
This one.
Soon, TM, soon, TM.
Yeah.
All right.
Well, that's probably a good.
good time to call it there but i thank you so much everyone
for coming and look forward to you guys have got uh have you
guys got debut 2.0s tomorrow as well um what's your schedule
looking like i am leaving i will be in the sky oh okay not
me so then have so much fun in the sky yeah have fun in the
sky thank you thank you i hope they feed you well in the sky
sometimes they feed you sometimes I hope so too man British
Airways you go around the back you can get some Cadbury on
your long long haul Japan flight for me pretty good yeah
yeah yeah it's pretty good yeah wow something something a
jet to holiday oh no nothing beats a jet to holiday nothing
beats a jet to holiday oh baby you've got it You got a
stream, right?
No?
Yeah, I haven't set up my waiting room yet.
I don't think, unless it's been set up for me.
I also haven't, yeah.
I guess.
It'll be at, mine will be 2 p.m.
Pacific time or 5 p.m.
Eastern time tomorrow.
Yippee!
Yay!
And I can't wait to, yeah.
I'm so excited.
I hope I can make it along.
Mine's, I think, a little bit later after Phoebe's at, no
idea American time.
1 p.m.
JST I think 8 p.m.
PT I think if I'm not mistaken.
Yeah, and 11 p.m.
ET.
Yeah, late night, late night yapping and snacks.
So, yeah, I'll see you guys there.
And with that, should we, we could try it again if you like.
Try the cool and response again.
Yeah, yeah, we could try.
All right.
Okie dokie.
Go Minter.
Oh, real quick.
Vicky's, so it's GMT the...
Is GMT the UK time?
Yeah, currently, yeah.
Okay, they were asking.
That's 4 a.m.
British time.
Yeah, very early.
But I have got some EU-friendly streams next week.
I'll be around half at the same time, half at a more
EU-friendly time next week.
So I hope to see you guys at those ones.
Yeah!
Yippee!
Woo-hoo!
Yeah.
Alrighty.
Go, go, you're a ray.
Go, go, go, go.
Let's go.
Yurei!
Yosei!
Yokai!
You!
Me!
Why did we all say it the same way?
That's Chat's canonical voice all.
Me, me, me.
Be a part of our story!
We are...